it's September 7th 2018 so it's time for
another monthly update video in this one
I will talk about what is going on in
September and what you might have missed
from August and I always like to begin
by talking about three big things so big
thing number one stoical on in London at
the end of the month I will be there
delivering a workshop and meeting and
greeting people as the editor of
Stoicism today and we've got a lot of
business to handle as well so if you're
going to be in the area I'll be happy to
meet with you and and yeah I'll
hopefully get to record a video big
thing number two stoical Week is coming
up immediately after that that's
happening the first week of October
starting on the 1st and continuing to
the seventh so I'll talk more about that
in just a bit and then big thing number
three I'm going to another conference
where I don't have to talk I'm not on
deck to do anything but I've been
invited as a guest and that is myth con
here in Milwaukee a little bit earlier
in the month that's on the 22nd so what
went on in the month of August I as I
tallied up all the different talks and
events and guest appearances they were
actually quite a few which makes me feel
a little bit better about the things
that didn't get done in in the month of
August that I'll talk about in just a
bit
so I gave talks here locally at in
different talk series the worlds of
speculative fiction we talked about
arthur c clarke there was a great
discussion that we had the video for
that is available down below we also had
the quarterly series philosophers in the
midst of history and this time we talked
about John Locke and his you know impact
on theories of government but also some
other important areas in philosophy and
in culture I did my doctor Sadler am
my philosophy pop-ups half-hour Hagel
sessions those are all online events
that that people can participate in we
also did a workshop here locally in the
Milwaukee area for Sophia that's the
Society of philosophers in America a
workshop for students and faculty of you
know high school
what was it history and English and we
actually had an art person there as well
departments how they can bring more
philosophy stuff into their classes and
sort of strategies for dealing with
issues that are likely to arise when you
do that so that was great and I I was
also on the image for hire radio show
with my my friend the skräuss and we
talked the entire time about philip k
dick and his novels we straight into a
lot of other things as well I was very
very busy this month I had a few new
clients for our tutorials and
philosophical counseling I've been doing
a lot of consulting work as well and of
course this time of the year is when
classes start and if you're a college
professor who actually you know is
teaching the right way then you're not
just on deck the first day of class the
entire month before that you're building
out course content you're you know
tweaking your syllabus there's all sorts
of meetings to go to and and so that's
what I was doing a good bit of this this
last month in addition to you know
helping clients in a variety of ways so
I didn't get much writing done and the
writing that I did do is largely for
stoicism today as we gear up for
international stoical week which is a
big thing you know we not only have the
class there's events all over the world
and and I try to put them into stoicism
today so that we can track all of these
sorts of things so there's a lot of
coordination involved with that I didn't
get much video
Oh done this this month I actually
didn't shoot any new half-hour hagel
videos which was a first for me I did
shoot some aristotle material i shot
some some cicero material that you'll
see much later on shot a little bit more
of pascal and then there was the event
videos but other than that I didn't get
to most of the things that I had planned
for the month and even this I'm shooting
quite quite late I did release some
podcast episodes so I finished up with
Kierkegaard's fear and trembling for the
time being I might do stuff in you know
the later parts of the work down the
line but there's a whole slew of podcast
episodes available and I've been
releasing podcast episodes on Cicero's
stoic paradoxes those were actually
edited by my son Matthew so that's
what's been going on in the month of
August alright so what is going on this
month of September let's start by
talking about events both face-to-face
and online tomorrow that is September
8th Saturday at 12 p.m. Central time I
will be having my doctor's Sadler's AMA
that's asking me anything session I do
that through YouTube live so the link is
below you can actually sign up already
to get alerted when when it's going to
start so you can ask your questions and
get them answered make sure to ask them
early on because as they pile up I can't
get to all of them it's becoming more
and more of a popular event then on the
13th at 7 p.m. here locally at the
Brookfield Public Library we'll have our
next worlds of speculative fiction
series 1 I've been looking forward to
very much and it's on gene Wolfe's book
of the New Sun which is this four-part
or sometimes you can think of it as a
five-part series and that's that's
that's gonna be you know a lot of fun I
started reading wolf back when I was a
high school student
maybe I was middle school I don't know I
remember picking up one of those the the
very first book in that the shadow of
the torture at a drugstore reading
through it quite avidly on the 19th at 3
p.m. Central Time another online event
will have our public Hagel Q&A session
and then the 29th if you're in London
and you're you've got tickets for
snowicon' I will be giving two workshops
two versions of the same workshop on the
stoic heart my wife was supposed to
co-present with me but she hasn't been
cleared for travel unfortunately so I'll
just be me but she'll have a lot of
input into how we're structuring the
workshop and what we're doing and I will
be hopefully getting a good recording of
it so if you can't make it then you you
can certainly see that once it's
released the other thing that I'll be
doing as I mentioned earlier is going to
myth Khan here in Milwaukee and myth
Khan is a a Khan it's it's it's a
one-day sort of series of talks and
panel discussions I'd say if you had to
pick the one thing that it's oriented
around the most its controversy and free
speech if you go onto their site you'll
see the speakers that they have lined up
they're kind of all over the ideological
spectrum but they're deaf quite a few of
them are definitely provocative so it'll
be fun just to go and see how that goes
I might do a little bit of writing about
it if I have the time and the
inclination and you know if possible it
might actually interview some of the
speakers or panelists if they're if
they're up for it so that's the events
that are coming up I'm right in the
middle of teaching my classes now we're
in full swing I've got two classes at
Marquette University one is foundations
in philosophy it's sort of like a amped
up intro to philosophy class you could
say and then I'm teaching business
ethics from Marquette as well and really
enjoy
that class one I haven't taught for a
few years but I'm able to bring all this
experience that I've got from working
with corporate clients and CEOs and
talking about these issues with them to
bear on that so that's a lot of fun and
then I'm teaching philosophies of human
nature over at the Milwaukee Institute
of Art and Design another really fun
class and and we're going through a lot
of cool texts shooting videos for that
I'll talk about that in the video part
doing a good bit of consulting work as
well mostly in ethics again and doing
quite a bit of tutorial work as students
gear up for the new semester what else
have we got going on I'm trying to get
to doing some writing and actually once
I finish this I have to go over to shut
up and write where I'm going to
deliberately not you know answer emails
or work on stuff or stoicism today but
just try to do some actual writing of my
own for some of these blogs that I
either write for or have that I haven't
been getting to video work I'm going to
try to get my 6 half-hour Haegele videos
done this month last month I didn't get
any done this month they want to get
back on the horse and and get it going
back full speed you'll see event videos
from you know the gene wolf discussion
and hopefully from the stoic on
presentation as well for my classes I'm
shooting more core concept videos you've
already seen some of them
you know that's particularly the
Aristotle ones and I'm going to be
shooting more stuff on Aristotle some
stuff on Cicero some stuff on Augustine
and I'm going to be releasing the
Kierkegaard videos that I was able to
get done earlier this summer that I
early released to my patreon supporters
and now I'll release them to the general
public
I'm hoping to do a few personal videos
as well and maybe some some interviews
with different people either from myth
Con or stoic on
or some of the people that I know here
locally and one of the things I really
really do need to get to are these book
reviews because the books keep piling up
and I haven't done any of those for a
while so I've got my work cut out for me
for September a lot of things going on I
should put in one one other thing too we
are in the process of building out the
calendar for next year so if you're
interested in having me come in and give
a talk or a workshop or anything along
those lines go ahead and email me at
Gregg at reason IO and we'll get talking
about that because the calendar will
fill up fairly quickly I think and if
you're interested in in you know
tutoring philosophical counseling or
coaching consulting work any of those
sorts of matters go ahead and email me
there as well Greg at reason IO comm
hope that you have a great month hope
that I see you in some of these online
events and stay tuned for the videos and
podcast episodes to come